foreign
Johnson I am the owner of Aunt Cheryl's
Cafe located right here in Braddock
Pennsylvania I'm Steve Mann uh I'm a
business owner in Braddock I was a
government contractor for 40 years now I
own a lot of real estate in Braddock and
I just helped to develop the time
because of fetterman we're here in this
location this building was his this was
his building he was the one that wanted
a restaurant in the community he was the
one that wanted Aunt Cheryl's to come
here in the community we are the only
female minority business in Braddock so
fetterman was the one that brought us
here he is for people he is for
Grassroots people he is for people in
the community he wants to see the
community grow he wants to see people
grow so that's what fetterman did for us
as a business owner and Braddock
fetterman has never helped my business
all the business studies owners I've
talked to he's never done anything for
he's a person who does as opposed to
talking you won't hear him say a lot of
um his vision is bigger than Braddock
and so that's what he does is he makes
opportunities for people to be able to
come in here and make a difference
I don't see how fetterman could be
taking credit for anything because he
hasn't done anything down here veteran
he dresses and card hard clothing but he
has never worked a day in his life that
I know of he's just dressed up like a
working man
but he's not really a working man the
people in Braddock know that fetterman
isn't a working type of guy his court
heart would never get dirty I have 20
some properties here that I redid
rehabbed completely with my own money
not using tax dollars
and uh fetterman he hasn't done anything
to rehab the town except for the
warringer building there's a new
apartment complex called the oranger
building and that's a building that's
for artists so he also helped with that
providing a place for artists to be able
to live at so not only has he provide
opportunities for businesses he's also
provided opportunities for housing for
people to be able to stay in affordable
housing right here in Braddock and
fetterman did put us on the map without
him
it would have uh probably just stayed
the same it did get a little better when
you first came in but since then it
really hasn't improved more people moved
out there's still drug dealers here
um the crime is has gone up it's still
distressed
poverty time the biggest thing that John
did was he brought the community
together again believing in having hope
that they can do things and that things
can happen in Braddock I like them but I
don't like his political views other
than that I would support him he's
moderate I would support veteran but
he's not a moderate he's
too far to the left
they're in that AOC the squad type of
people
and it's bad for the country bad for our
kids
[Music]